if you find that thing that's pulling
you out of bed that you think about
first thing in the morning and you think
about when you go to bed at night
that's when you know you found the right
problem to go out and solve you don't
have to push yourself to do it it
doesn't require willpower and even the
best Founders willpower never lasts over
a sustained period of Time find your why
and you'll be able to get through just
about any how
[Music]
Sparrow built what expedia did for
travel but we do it in lending so
through Sparrow borrowers can submit a
single application and we will
underwrite that application on behalf of
a network of lenders Across the Nation
and return back the most affordable
options for them
I was a junior at Stanford and it was a
time when everybody got sent home as a
result of covid during that time we
recognized very first hand and
intimately how Antiquated the private
student lending system was you know we
watched our friends get sent home and it
was easier to find that flight to go
back home than it was to find the loan
to fund their school as a result we
questioned why why does the same
convenience that exists since say travel
not exist in lending there wasn't a good
answer so we decided to build a solution
we've raised 6.7 million dollars to date
we've facilitated over 200 million
dollars of searched loan volume for
private student loans on the refi side
per loan we've saved borrowers about 9.6
thousand dollars we've had signed over
17 lenders onto the platform we have 17
universities across the United States
currently running on Sparrow for their
private student loan search and we have
a little over fifteen thousand users who
have used the platform to fund that
in-school private student loan
foreign
the experience has been a massive
Learning Journey I mean in the beginning
we were making every mistake he could
make possible we didn't have the right
things in decks we weren't presenting
the total addressable Market classic
things that you'd want in an investor
deck it took us about six to seven
months to raise that pre-seed round it
was a grind we were trying to find the
right partner who could see in the
vision and invest in a group of 22 23
year olds who didn't really know what
they were doing but after we nailed our
value proposition and started to find
product Market fit the rest of the
raising came came pretty seamlessly
[Music]
you have to stay flexible you set a plan
and you execute upon that plan but
cancellation for example or the payment
pause throws wrench in those plans and
what you do is you just adapt you know
what your plan B your plan C and even
sometimes your plan D is and you know
iterate effectively we were all for the
cancellation and all for forgiveness at
the end of the day we basically want to
do such a good job we no longer have a
job we want to be there for borrowers we
want to help them affordably Finance
College
operating in a space that is under
political scrutiny constantly and the
only time it makes headlines is for the
wrong reason has definitely put pressure
on ourselves to make sure that we say
the right things to make sure that we
build the product in the right way but
always having that North Star and
knowing that we're in the borrower's
best interest has guided us through that
don't be afraid to take that risk so
often was I hesitant to say something in
investor meeting or to pitch a
prospective client because I didn't
think we deserved their business or to
talk about Sparrow in a grandiose way to
borrowers because our product had
limited scope taking that risk is more
than just you know leaving the job and
starting a company it involves the daily
interactions that you have with all the
key stakeholders across the board
for myself three years ago I wish I
would have taken more risk but
calculated risk you're not gonna you
know throw yourself into something
without understanding what the potential
downfall might be but you take those
risks in spite of the outcome not
because of it
[Music]